good to see you again mary nice to meet
you hey
youtube violations on the season
so mary knows i do my homework so i
might have watched
an instagram live video that the two of
you did
so wondering how did growing close
behind the scenes affects your
relationship
on screen especially given the fact that
it's the complete
opposite type between the two characters
i started to like mary and it was
horrible
and i couldn't act anymore and it was
just
a whole thing i mean i agree
it's definitely easier when uh you don't
know somebody to just like blindly hate
them
um you know people on the internet do
that up to me all the time that's fine
[Laughter]
but no but it's actually it is like it's
easier in a way but honestly like
getting to know payton more
makes me take our scenes even more
seriously because i'm
for one thing it adds a layer of like
all right i gotta remember to look angry
um but it also means that i i feel like
i have more going into it i'm like all
right like
if i'm really gonna challenge myself
like peyton sat
in my seat at lunch now i'm gonna be mad
about that not mad as sam and i'm mad as
mary
just kidding you're fine you never do
anything wrong i love that it almost
feels like
you're going to bed at a sleepover and
you're under the sleeping bag next to
your friend and we're like okay we're
about to be angry okay
all right i'll see you in a second
i think you just go away and you come
back and it's like
our you know our personal lives leave
and luckily we're able to separate that
but i was saying earlier i understand
why some actors don't interact with
people they're supposed to hate and they
kind of keep their distance and
you know they interact with the people
they're supposed to love and bond with
and that and that's it
um i i get that too but mary and i we
found
and we became we became friends last
season and um
that was cool the technique you guys
came up with works
mighty well another thing i pulled from
that video
is for you peyton because i was hearing
about the buzzfeed quiz and
the description for tori at the end
specifically when it says she has a
heart of gold
that descriptor immediately sounded
wrong to me
but then i started to think about it and
i questioned it so
for you playing the character do you
think there is truth in that and is that
ever on your mind in the scenes
yeah it is because in my head i'm always
right and i'm always doing what's right
and i'm fighting
for what's best and i'm fighting for
justice and everything else so
i think yeah i think my character does
have a heart of gold
she from her perspective you know
sam has wronged her and seen the worst
in her
so i think you know and and even with my
friends with you know i'm friends with
aisha and i'm friends with
miguel and i like miguel and you know
sam is trying to steal him away from me
and from
and she seems like this you know
privileged
girl that i've you know i'm threatened
by because i've never seen anything like
that and i
can't even imagine her having any
problems or her and i can't imagine her
world so to me
it all makes sense but you know looking
from the outside
i can see my heart would be questionable
i see it hopefully we'll see it emerge
more in the future
yeah mary got a lot of heavy lifting to
do this season
so what is the prep process like in
terms of getting into that kind of
headspace that sam is a bit stuck in
i think uh i was really excited to like
get into it i was really excited to
get serious uh in different and new ways
um
you know and and especially with with
this season's arc it was
really it was not easy but it was
relatable to me in a new way i got to
like bring new parts of myself to
samantha that i
hadn't gotten to bring along yet uh
brought out my new baggage
and started unpacking it oh so fun um
but
actually that was it was really uh
therapeutic and rewarding um
not necessarily easy but i'm really
excited for people to see it because i
tried to play it as honest and true as i
could
and uh there is a lot of of me in
samantha
this year i applaud you big time
i thought it played very very well i
just can't believe that
season three somehow exceeded my
expectations so
thank you guys for that i appreciate
that i feel like that's a tough that's
tough but i appreciate it